horror movies are filled of people who
make stupid moose would be slasher
victims trip over their own feet as they
flee police never believe anyone who
claims a killer is on the loose and
everybody always assumes the monster is
dead just because it's down sometimes
however a horror movie features a
character so overwhelmingly dumb you
almost can't help but wonder whether
they actually deserve their grisly fate
here are a few of the most facepalm
worthy moments in fright flick history
Lambert's folly Ridley Scott's 1979
masterpiece alien may have
revolutionized the horror and sci-fi
genres but that doesn't mean as
characters weren't prone to the
occasional moment of frustrating
stupidity let's put aside the obvious
that the Nostromo crew should never have
let Kane out of quarantine and briefly
shine a light on Veronica Cartwright
character Joan Lambert
cornered by the xenomorph as a crew
preps the Nostromo for self-destruction
Lambert reacts quite well by not
reacting at all chief engineer Dennis
Parker sacrifices himself in an attempt
to save her throwing himself at the
towering monster the Lambert still just
remains planted to the ground unable to
do anything but cry and scream
helplessly
[Music]
and surprisingly she doesn't make it
Parker deserved better space mistakes
Prometheus may not have lived up to the
high standards set by some of its
predecessors but that's not to say it
wasn't a sufficiently creepy movie even
if it featured his fair share of
boneheaded decisions the first comes
courtesy of Rafe's pals character
Melbourne who encounters a snake-like
creature inside a mysterious alien
temple Melbourne a biologist decides the
best thing to do in that situation is to
reach out and touch it
you can probably guess what happens next
then we've got vicars after the
Prometheus self-destructs by ramming
into the spacecraft of the movies
villainous engineers the flaming
wreckage comes crashing down towards her
and a fellow Explorer Elizabeth Shore
the ship hits the planet's surface and
begins rolling towards them like a wheel
Vickers for some reason attempts to
outrun it rather than say taking a few
steps to the side
life hacks James Wan saw helped
popularize the torch upon sub-genre with
a Tara drenched Odyssey of elaborate and
grotesque death traps the star of the
show is dr. Lawrence Gordon the
oncologist turned prisoner who
ultimately ends up taking drastic
measures to escape his shackles except
he didn't really need sir believing his
wife and daughter to be in danger after
talking to them on the phone but unable
to reach his cell phone because he
accidentally lost it Lawrence proceeds
to use a hacksaw to cut through his
lower leg and free himself had he
thought to just use a saw to pull the
phone towards him he might have
discovered his family was safe without
having to cut off his own foot blowing a
good lead when screams Ghostface killer
attempts a corner Tatum Riley in a
garage she actually does a pretty good
job of defending herself
things fall apart however when she
decides to attend an escape by diving
through a small dog entrance cut into
the garage door obviously it doesn't
work let's not kid ourselves either this
scene was probably nothing more than an
excuse for some close-up shots of a
braless rose mcgowan in a short skirt
struggling to fit her upper torso
through a small door a shocking twist
whilst it follows was lauded for its
chilling intelligence and deft handling
of mature themes the movie nonetheless
suffered from the inclusion of a
devastating and intelligent choice made
by his lead characters in an effort to
bring an end to the deadly entity that
stalks my commom Rose character J she
and her friends concoct a plan to trap
the creature in a swimming pool filled
with live electrical devices thanks in
part to the fact that said creature is
immortal this plan doesn't exactly work
even director David Robert Mitchell
pointed out the trap wasn't particularly
well thought out he said it's a kid
movie plan something that scooby-doo and
the gang might think of they do their
best to accomplish something and we
witness its failure Laurie snafu in
Halloween h2o Jamie Lee Curtis his
character Laurie appears to finally
defeat her murderous brother Michael
Myers after cutting off his head when
it's revealed that the man she killed
was actually a paramedic donning her
brother's signature headpiece however
she's forced to face him all over again
and makes a mistake that costs at dla
when she's given another chance to kill
Myers in Halloween Resurrection Laurie
reaches out to pull off his mask and
double-check that it really is her
brother standing in front of her at the
same time she fails to realize that his
hands are still free giving him the
perfect opportunity to turn the tables
on her see you in hell
[Music]